[موسيقى]
تشتهر ولايه نزوى بمساجدها القديمه
والتاريخيه المنتشره في ارجاعها لا سيما
في حاره العقر المكان الاقدم في الولايه
والمتاخم لقلعتها العريقه
[موسيقى]
التاريخ هنا يلمس باليدين فهذا المسجد
يمتد عمره لاكثر من 1400 عام ولا يزال
شاهدا على تاريخ ولايه نزوى الديني
والاجتماعيه
[موسيقى]
مسجد الشواذنه يعتبر ثاني مسجد بني في
سلطنه عمان في السنه التاسعه للهجره
ويتميز المسجد بمحرابه المليء بالنقوش
الاسلاميه التي يعود عمرها الى سنه
936 المسجد قضى على العديد من عمليات
الترميم للحفاظ عليه اخرها كان عام 2003
[موسيقى]
ايضا حاره العقر تضم مسجدا تاريخيا اسمه
مسجد مزارعه يعود تاريخ بنائه الى القرن
الثالث الهجري يتميز بوجود كتابات تاريخيه
على سقفه تعود لحقب مختلفه كتبت على خشب
من اشجار اللوز والعلام الماخوذه من الجبل
الاخضر القريبين من الولايه تميز هذا
المسجد بانه بني على قاعده مرتفعه كما
يتميز هذا المسجد بانه من اوسع المساجد
الموجوده في حاره العقبه حيث يوجد به اربع
سواري كما يتميز بالمحراب الذي يتميز من
اعلاب النقوش الاثريه القديمه يوجد
بالمسجد كتابات على جدرانه توثيق الاحداث
التاريخيه التي حدثت في تلك الفتره
سواء كان من حرائق او من احداث او من غلاء
الاسعار في بعض المواد المستهلكه في ذلك
الوقت كما يوثق ايضا المناسبات الاجتماعيه
وبعض حالات الوفاه لا قدر الله
[تصفيق]
العصيمي من ولايه نزوى العربيه
[موسيقى]